écrire une lettre postale à l'ancienne
sur un papier avec un crayon c'est
vraiment un petit plaisir que j'ai
retrouvé en fait j'ai eu un petit
problème avec ma banque
alors je les ai appelés et la dame au
téléphone elle m'a dit
[Musique]
alors je me suis mis à écrire cette
lettre hewitt quelques lignes j'ai
redécouvert un problème que j'avais en
co2 alors que j'ai 24 ans l'écriture
pencher enfin c'est ridicule ce truc
j'ai 24 ans j'écris encore penché
heureusement que je pose pas un
entretien d'embauché
alors je sors d'une école d'ingénieur je
suis trilingue professionnel est
extrêmement motivé voici ma lettre de
motivation comme ridicule du coup j'ai
dû tracer des lignes avec une règle au
crayon pour écrire mais bon après je les
ego mais je ne suis pas complètement fou
non plus j'ai aussi un truc que j'avais
oublié maintenant que j'ai l'habitude
d'envoyer des emails des textos et
autres tout de manière parfaitement
illimité c'est que pour envoyer une
lettre postale extrêmement ringarde qui
va mettre trois jours à arriver il faut
payer
what is ce fut que nos parents à
l'époque il devait dépenser trop de
thunes pour la fête de samedi soir je
sais pas encore si je peux venir
écoute je te confirme sa part lettre ok
on fait comme ça ça marche
ah non j'ai plus de crédit donc j'ai dû
aller acheter un timbre est un truc que
j'ai toujours trouvé hyper dégueulasse
avec les timbres ses yeux un timbre à
part à la poste tu peux l'acheter que
dans les vieux pmu vraiment crado et la
partie non protégés du timbre il faut
tout simplement la lécher
alors si personne ne regarde moi je fais
la technique du doigt
[Musique]
comme ça j'ai pas trop trop de maladie
du pmu et enfin après avoir bien galéré
quand j'arrive devant la boîte aux
lettres pour poster à l'être j'ai
l'impression de devenir plutôt des deals
et des idées pendant quarante cinquante
secondes
mais après avoir autant galéré j'ai pas
envie de me tromper que tout ce que tu
veux
suite à quoi je développe une sorte de
parano boni que si ça se trouve la
lettre n est pas bien tombé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors que normalement c'est un coup
classique
je sais pas si je suis le seul à galérer
pour envoyer une lettre de merde en tout
cas vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux
sur la page facebook norman fait des
vidéos et ça ça me fait super plaisir
partagé d'accord au fait si tout d'un
coup vous voulez vous la péter et
prendre un stylo plume pour écrire votre
lettre
ça fait partie des choses qui sont des
mauvaises idées mauvaise idée
si tu souffle dans le ballon tu es mort
si tu accélères ils pourront peut-être
patratras p mauvaise idée
tu as l'impression ta petite copine vous
paraît tu cherche à lui faire un enfant
pour la garder mauvaise idée
tu veux faire marrer tombe au père tu
fait des allusions sur la nuit dans sa
fille que tu as passé
mauvaise idée commencez la clope à 30
ans président et les mélanges d'alcools
différents à
[Musique]